welcome to another developer update my
name is Jeff I'm one of the developers
on the overwatch team this update is
going to be very cool because it is a
topic a lot of you have been asking
about four months and we're really
excited to address what's going on so
coming to the PTR very soon are going to
be the much-awaited symetra changes so I
want to spend a little bit of time and
kind of go through the changes and why
we made them so obviously the problem we
were seeing with symetra before and
we've talked about this a little bit
before was that she was a very effective
character but she was viewed as overly
situational and what I mean by that is
players enjoyed playing her but usually
they would play her in a situation where
maybe they were on defense on the first
point for example in kings row they do
they play her on the first point she
seems super useful when you get the
teleporter up keep it protected and get
your team back to the fight really
quickly but what we found is if a team
failed on that first point a lot of
players would either switch off a
Symetra or stay on symetra not be as
effective because in essence her entire
ultimate ability was not useful on later
points even though sometimes players
would put up that teleporter on the
final point of like a temple of Anubis
or even in kings row it really wasn't
helping as much as it helped earlier in
the match so that is one of the things
that we wanted to address and we also
want to address some quality of life
issues a lot of times we got feedback
about the initial setup with symetra and
how that felt as a symmetric player that
sort of panicked rush that you would
make to put shields on everybody and
then run to the front line and get your
turrets going to try to build ultimate
as fast as you could but then you were
waiting on cooldowns a lot and it was
kind of frustrating and there was a
weird time efficiency element to it that
wasn't ultimately fun but just more
stress inducing and put a lot of
pressure on you so to get into some of
the changes were making with symetra
let's start with her ultimate because
that's probably the most exciting so
symetra is going to be the first
character in overwatch to actually have
a choice of Ultimates she will have two
Ultimates available to her at all times
in the match so what will happen is
she'll start with no ultimate in terms
of her ult meter will be at zero just
like other heroes doing damage and over
time the altimeter will increase when
your alt is available to you your your
ultimate will light up and at first you
will see the teleporter there so just
like symetra played previous to this you
can put the teleporter down it works
just the same as it did before you have
six charges your teammates can come
through but what is very exciting is you
can also toggle by pressing your
ultimate ability again to a shield
generator so the shield generator is a
built object just like the teleporter
but it puts a very substantial shield
more than her old shields on all of her
teammates in a very big radius and it
ignores line of sight so that means
symmetric can actually hide the shield
generator somewhere it's applying
shields to everybody and the other team
really needs to go find that before they
can take out that shield generator or
take out those shields so she now has
two buildable objects for her ultimate a
choice of a teleporter or a choice of a
shield generator the other thing we did
was look at her teleporter and we gave
it more health and we made some of the
health shield health instead which means
that it regenerates so a problem before
was as a Symetra you defend either your
teleporter or in the new scenario you'll
also defend your shield generator and it
would take some damage and you there's
no recourse you couldn't undo that at
all so even though we always intended
symetra to sort of build a nest and
protect what she had built it wasn't
realistic because sometimes it would
just get taken out even if you had
successfully taking out the person who
is attacking it so it has more health
now and more of that health is in shield
so or regenerate over time meaning the
enemy team has to make a more concerted
effort to go after your ultimate that
you've built so you might be asking you
know with the shield generator what
happened to the shields so we felt that
the shields were never a really highly
interactive fun sort of element to
playing symetra at times it felt more
like a chore or almost like plate
spinning but not in a great way so
instead we've replaced it with a
completely new ability it's called
photon barrier and what this is is very
similar to maybe Reinhardt shield or
Winston's projected barrier that he
creates it's it's a barrier that that
symetra has but what's cool about hers
is that it's actually projected on a
track of movement so it's it's sort of
elliptical in shape and she sends it out
and it just moves along a trajectory so
it's really effective like if you're
sort of hanging behind your team and
they don't have somebody like a
Reinhardt maybe they have a road hog
Nazari as their tanks up front you can
send this projected barrier out in front
of you and it sort of signals your whole
team to come with it and follow with it
but it's got way more uses than that
symmetric can use it for her own devices
as well protecting her nest or using it
to be very aggressive so we think the
photon barrier will be a really fun
active addition to symmetric toolkit
that puts more skill in playing the hero
and then also just a lot more creativity
and how you play her so we think you'll
enjoy that the other thing we've done is
we made some minor tweaks to her her
turrets themselves the little century
turrets that she placed out previously
she could always have six out in the map
but previously you could only stock up
to three place those and then you'd have
to wait for the cooldown to regenerate
we've changed that maximum 26 so when
the match starts for example or when
setup starts symmetric can run out and
instantly place six of our turrets in a
location that she wants and then they're
still on cooldown after that to come
back but added at a slightly different
rate
now increase its 10 seconds where it was
12 seconds before what this means for
symetra players is one the initial setup
in the map is much more like you want it
to be you can kind of pick your area set
up exactly how you want at the start of
the match the other area that that
really is a game-changer for this is it
allows symetra to sort of move her
location with the flow of combat much
easier you know you might be defending a
choke early in the match and then decide
that you want to drop back and quickly
put a bunch of turrets up on a capture
point or maybe around the payload and
now you have a lot more tools at your
disposal to to make that type of move
really quickly so we think that should
be a lot of fun we made some minor
tweaks to erupts it for the most part
her weapon works exactly the same as it
did before both the primary and
secondary fire are exactly the same as
they were with a slight change to the
primary fire we've extended the distance
of the beam at which it locks on so
symmetric can actually make contact with
targets slightly further out it's not
much more you know don't panic she's not
you know a long-range beam sniper now or
anything like that she's still a very
short-range character with that primary
fire but just for quality of life we
gave it a little bit more distance so
that should feel better as well so all
of these changes are coming very soon to
the PTR so we want your feedback we want
you to play with it and we'd really love
to hear both from the Symetra players
you play a lot of symetra we want to
hear you know how does this feel to you
but we're also really curious to hear
from the non symmetric players you know
maybe you didn't play her before because
she wasn't fun or you know the skill cap
wasn't where you wanted it to be or you
know some other quality of life reason
you know is symmetric better for you as
now as well so we'd love to hear all
your thoughts on symetra will be taking
a very close look at the statistics
seeing you know what's her win right
like our people switching off of her on
the second point is she effective on
attack now is she effective in
control maps like Nepal illios lijiang
were really looking at symetra overall
and holistically we want her to be a
less situational character in a
character that sees a lot more use so we
hope you have fun with her we've had her
in internal testing for quite some time
now and she feels very powerful to us so
we'll see how she feels to you guys we
always get a much better sense from you
guys we're a very small group who's
testing internally so we get a much
better idea from you guys so that's the
big update there's a couple of the
things I wanted to make you aware of
Oasis the the new map that we mentioned
at blizzcon which is a control map again
like you know li Shang Nepal illios
Oasis is coming to the PTR very soon
very shortly after symetra will get 0
ASIS on there for testing our goal again
is to put Oasis live to the service to
everybody in early 2017 but we'd like to
get as much testing you know at the end
of 2016 as possible on the map we think
it's a lot of fun one thing in
particular that we're keeping an eye on
is that jump pad we want to see all the
creative uses you guys can come up with
it and if that's a mechanic that's
really fun and we refine it along with
you guys maybe that's something we do
more of in future iterations of either
overwatch Maps or future / watch heroes
so keep an eye out for Oasis and then
one final small feature that I'll
mention to you guys and I'm not sure
which iteration of the PTR it will hit
on but keep an eye out for it we've
added a small social feature at the end
of a match when the match ends and
you're looking at some of the statistics
and the end of round flow where you see
see the cards the statistics the play of
the game we've added a small button on
the screen that just says stay with
group or I want to party up now and and
basically what we've added this for is
those times where you've been really
successful with the team but you guys
aren't friends you're not on each
other's friends list but you're like wow
we had a lot of great chemistry
it sure would be awesome if we could
kind of keep this group together and if
you all click on that button or even
some of you click on that button it will
automatically form a party for you guys
and then you can keep playing together
so that's just one of the small social
features we're going to keep making ones
like that to really encourage people to
group up hang out play more you know
hopefully make friends find those people
with similar place i'll see you that you
enjoy playing with because we think it
really enhances the experience that's
all we have for today we're super
excited to see what you guys do with the
new symetra and eventually how you guys
play the new map oasis as always we're
looking forward to your feedback you
guys really are the one searing the
direction of this game we hope you enjoy
and have a great time with it we'll see
you later